the circle of life continues it's been
25 years since Disney released the Lion
King film the 2019 version will be a
reintroduction of the story to audiences
around the world here's everything you
need to know before you go this story
takes place in an African animal kingdom
called the pride lands The Lion King is
the highest-grossing 2d animation of all
time in the United States it won two
Academy Awards for its music and the
Golden Globe Award for Best Motion
Picture Musical or Comedy
[Music]
and in 1997 a Broadway adaptation of the
film opened and won six Tony Awards
including Best Musical Jon Favreau
directed this 2019 photorealistic film
Disney was happy to have him at the helm
due to the massive success of his
reimagining of the jungle book released
in 2016 we're wondering if we can expect
a shot-for-shot remake of The Lion King
one of its trailers is a perfect echoing
of the original 1994 Lion King trailers
the story of the original film centers
around Simba a lion cub who is set to
inherit the king's throne from his
father Mufasa scar
Mufasa brother was next in line before
Simba's birth after losing his grasp of
the power seat he becomes envious and
vengeful against his family he hatches a
plan with a pack of hyenas to attain the
power that he so desperately craves this
one
thus my teeth and ambitions our third
baby
so he puts his nephew Simba directly in
harm's way to steal his position in line
Mufasa
Simba's brave and protective father
rescues his son as Mufasa is trying to
escape from the gorge scar betrays him
ultimately accomplishing his goal scar
places the blame on Simba for his
father's death and convinces him to
leave his family and Pride Rock behind
along his journey of survival and
self-discovery Simba meets Timon and
Pumbaa
[Music]
[Music]
after sometime Simba is an adult lion
and has thoughts about his destiny now
an adult Nala ventures off to hunt and
during her pursuit she and Simba happily
meet again it's like you're back from
the dead you don't know how much this
will mean to everyone Rafiki discovers
Simba is alive and guides him to
communicate with his father spirit you
can psycho so Simba what you have become
he then decides it's time to return home
and reclaim his rightful place as king
as you wish
and of course he must go through his
uncle Scar to do so
[Applause]
when he succeeds against scar he
breathes life back into the pride lands
and all is good again
this epic retelling of the Lion King
story is packed with major stars voicing
the characters that we love Donald
Glover is the lead as the adult Simba
Beyonce stars is adult Nala
Simba's childhood friend and love James
Earl Jones is reprising his role as the
almighty King Mufasa he's the only cast
member that remains the same from the
1994 film alfre woodard is queen lioness
Surabhi of Pride Rock chuyia tell
Ejiofor is the villainous uncle Scar
john connie is the wise and spiritual
Rafiki the top three hyenas as easy
Shenzi and kumari are played by
keegan-michael key
Eric Andre and Florence kazoomba Billy
Eichner and Seth Rogen are the
fun-loving duo Timon and Pumbaa and last
but not least John Oliver is why Zazu
Mufasa
trusted confidant the original Lion King
was cherished for its original songs so
we're wondering what kind of musical
numbers can we expect
are we getting new melodies any new
lyrics the version was all of us in a
room this is far away from each other
just like singing at each other's faces
he had to and yeah like as someone who
is not the greatest singer like it's
like haven't played basketball with like
LeBron James and it's like I don't like
a fool hey wait the return of mega
composer Hans Zimmer and the new edition
of super producer Pharrell Williams the
film is definitely in good hands and
let's not forget these songs are
performed by the sweet crooner Donald
Glover and queen bee herself what
excites you most about this new Lion
King let us know in the comments below
all right so now you know and now you
can go see the new and improved The Lion
King in theaters July 19
you
[Music]